well first of all congratulations on
1883
i'm loving this mother-daughter duo how
great has it been look at the way you
guys look at each other how great has it
been to work so closely together on this
project
it's been
hard work it's been fun i mean we've
done things well i think i can
definitely speak for myself but probably
isabel as well and she's capable of
speaking herself
we've done things that i that we've
never
imagined doing and done before we've had
a good time it's been hard work yeah and
it shows it's been hard work but doing
it with you my goodness she's one of a
kind
she's the loveliest person i've ever met
oliver took off for your tv mom that's
pretty cool
i'm as lucky as yeah i'm very lucky
i'm very lucky
there were two journeys
one was filled with danger and death and
despair
the other adventure and wonder
i was on the latcher
and you get to share the screen a lot
with her husband tim mcgraw as well now
going into this project were you a big
timing faith fan
nope she didn't even
stop it she still hasn't heard a dead
dumb one i know but i'm like i'm
actually i'm actively not listening to
any of their music just because i
they're yeah they're
you know
beautiful incredible singer human faith
well that made sense right total sense
well tim just announced a tour so you're
gonna have to go check that out next
year for sure is there music on this set
i know you guys are busy obviously
filming but in the down time that you
have do you guys do any music or i mean
felt out of tune every once in a while
[Laughter]
i think everyone has their
music playing in their ear pods or
something but
off you know on while on set no i really
they're really i mean i can only i don't
think so okay no no campfire sessions
have you no no i haven't heard any music
yeah
yeah i don't think we're having we're
having we're enjoying ourselves but
we're not necessarily having that
way you james dude yes sir
mind if we speak but if you're selling
ain't buying
daddy our families meet me here tonight
and we're heading north and we'll keep
heading north to lafayette country it's
worth the journey now faith you have the
best gig in the world being able to
share the screen with your husband how
special has this experience been for you
guys to be able to do it together
it's
been amazing honestly i mean isabelle
and tim
really have an incredible story that
floats through the uh this show um it's
remarkable the relationship they have uh
as father and and daughter
yeah we've never worked together in this
way yes we've made it a point to to not
work together when we're offset and i
will say this when i first came in
um
we were excited one two three four came
quickly and then they started trickling
in and we're like
we want more we want
i would read one episode than he would
read in episodes we may made that kind
of a thing between us but we don't
really
work
scenes outside of the set how much of
tim in faith as husband and wife do we
see in james and margaret or
do you try to keep that separate well i
think some things are just natural
because we are husband and wife and
there's some things you just
it is what it is um but what is
beautiful is to is to watch
uh the relationship that
that isabelle mm-hmm or i'm going to say
yeah isabel i won't say elsa
is is
isabel's character the relationship that
they have together and it's
it's kind of remarkable because
the writing
for
isabelle's character is just one of the
best things i've ever honestly the
script is one of the best things i've
ever read but her character
is just the strength the
it's powerful i mean she is a
a force to be reckoned with and as a
mother of three daughters and i consider
her my fourth child because that's how i
feel about her
but to to witness well to first read
a story like this but then to witness
isabel working these scenes and bringing
this character to life is is remarkable
because she it she's
heroic and and the writing for
a woman in general but a young woman
especially
uh
for her age is just like wow
it's kind of it's extraordinary so to
see
tim and and isabel work together they do
a lot of stuff together the girl writes
like crazy i'm like whoa slow down
but she's just going after it
yeah
about to hear that you're also a part of
the family now to hear all that what
does that mean to you
well it means the world but um
i don't know it makes it almost makes me
wanna it makes me very emotional
um
because i i love them dearly
and i do i do feel like
i don't know almost like their family
now
and
just being able to be a part of it do
this with them it's a dream come true
sometimes i pinch myself in the morning
just to know it's all real
they're such beautiful souls and
they've taken such good care of me and
looked out for me like they are my
parents
yeah it's
it's a dream come true i can't believe i
get to do it with them i really can't
but not
just who they are
they are the most authentic kind
individuals i've ever
some of the most authentic kind
individuals i've ever met you're gonna
make me cry there's a lot of them on the
set too there's a lot of great we yeah
we everyone really oh my god blessed
to for it to be such a grueling and hard
and and we were warned all of us were
warned this is not going to be a walk in
the park this is a different kind of
filming and and
but i think because of uh everyone's
commitment and just the people are just
fantastic honestly
great people and we've had we've had a
good time when we're not working we've
had a good time this one right here has
been working her little tail
i mean my god she's just about in
everything uh every scene and um it's
remarkable to watch yeah well you guys
hit the jackpot with the cast taylor
sheridan knows some good ones when he
sees them last question for you is about
obviously your character she gives me
some anxiety sometimes because i love
this this freshness to her this this
desire to experience life they weren't
poor
you weren't desperate
the road west is filled with failures
failure isn't what drove him
[Music]
it was a dream
and the dream is coming true
even if that means disobeying her
parents a little bit were you like that
in your teenage years too absolutely not
i was i was a very good child i mean i'm
saying that now i don't know how my
parents actually feel about that
maybe a little no i um
i liked reading books and spending time
with myself and okay not participating
and you know i was not a rebel but i
don't think she's a rebel either i think
she just is
gravitated towards new experiences and
can't help herself yeah it's that
refreshing zest for life everything is
so stimulating and exciting and she just
wants to grab at it and
experience everything to the fullest so
it's all good intentions exactly yeah
yes yes and you do you have to go into
mama mode do you have to channel your
inner mom in those disciplinary scenes
with elsa uh
i mean for sure you know but there are
different circumstances but yes i think
once a mom always a mom despite where
you are what you're doing there's just
been a remarkable way of witnessing
and and reminding ourselves
of the freedom of nature and what it it
does
for your soul
so
uh
try to be careful to realize that
as um
a beautiful young woman my
daughter our daughter i mean i know her
capabilities you know she's very capable
on horse on
everything and um
very intelligent and spirited uh curious
but when you have that kind of space
to free your
all of the inhibitions everything all
the i mean
there's just nothing greater than
freedom especially in wide open space
like we have been
whether it be freezing cold windy or
burning hot either one but that's the
unique thing about this project is we're
we're quite literally experiencing
everything that they would have but at
the end of the day we get to
leave it right and put on a warm coat or
yeah you know
and uh and it's been really
kind of insightful just to experience
that it has been because you think you
read a lot about and this girl here is i
mean she reads so much so many things
you read a lot of stories
back in the day
but i tell you we have definitely you do
you have to do when you have to do it
and because it is on set it is real and
and that's the truth and that's made it
i think
easier
and then also
it needs to be hard in order for us to
do a show like this it does not need to
be a walk in the park
you